.
BRET?
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL NOW WAIT FOR THE JURY.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL GET ANALYSIS FROM GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY LAW SCHOOL
PROFESSOR JONATHAN TURLEY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Bret: WE FOLLOWED THIS EVERY
DAY.
WHAT DO YOU LOOK AT HERE?
WHAT'S YOUR ASSESSMENT OF IT?
>> WELL, THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING, THE DEFENSE REALLY
DIDN'T LAY A GLOVE ON THE
EVIDENCE, THERE IS A VERY
DAMNING HE TEXT MESSAGE THE DAY
BEFORE THIS MEETING WHERE
SUSSMANN SAYS THAT I EXPRESSLY
SAYS I'M NOT HERE REPRESENTING A
CLIENT, I'M JUST COMING FORTH
BASICALLY A CITIZEN.
THE DURHAM PROSECUTION TEAM MADE
REALLY SHORT WORK OF THAT AND
SHOWED THAT HE WAS BILLING FOR
THAT TIME AND HE WAS INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN THE CREATION AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE ALPHA BANK
SCANDAL, WHICH PROVED TO BE
COMPLETELY GROUNDLESS.
BUT THERE WERE MOMENTS OF THE
TRIAL THAT WERE REALLY QUIET
BREATHTAKING.
I MEAN, YOU COULD SEE WHAT
DURHAM IS UP AGAINST.
AT ONE POINT HE ASKED BAKER, THE
FORMER FBI GENERAL COUNSEL, ONE
OF THE LAWYERS ASKED WHY DID YOU
WAIT TO GIVE US -- HAND OVER
THAT INCRIMINATING TEXT?
AND HE JUST SAYS SUSSMANN IS A
FRIEND OF MINE.
THIS IS YOUR INVESTIGATION.
NOT MINE.
ALL OF US WERE LIKE WOW, BECAUSE
YOU WERE ONE OF THE TOP PEOPLE
AT THE FBI AND YOU ARE TALKING
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO.
>> Bret: SO FOR SOMEBODY SITTING
AT HOME WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING OUT
THE FACTS AND DAY-TO-DAY
DEVELOPMENTS BUT PIECE IT ALL
TOGETHER FOR THEM.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER?
>> WELL, IT MATTERS A LOT.
WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT.
IT IS -- THERE HAS BEEN
QUESTIONS RAISED AS TO WHY THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION DID NOT
UNCOVER OR REVEAL SOME OF THESE
DETAILS.
WHAT WE NOW HAVE A VERY CLEAR
PATTERN IN BOTH THE STEELE
DOSSIER AND THE ALPHA BANK
SCANDAL.
BOTH OF THEM ORIGINATED WITH THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN HID THE
FUNDING OF THE STEELE DOSSIER.
WAS RECENTLY FINED BY THE FEC
FOR DOING THAT SO THEY PUSHED
THESE TWO SEPARATE PARALLEL
TRACKS.
BOTH WENT TO THE FBI.
BOTH WENT TO THE CIA.
BOTH WENT TO FAVORABLE PEOPLE IN
THE MEDIA.
AND THEY UNLEASHED THIS TORRENT
OF MEDIA ATTENTION.
>> Bret: WITHOUT TELLING THEM
THAT IT ORIGINALLY CAME FROM
SOMEBODY TIED TO THE CAMPAIGN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT WAS REALLY TELLING IS THIS
CAME OUT TOWARDS THE END OF THE
TRIAL.
ONE OF THE FBI AGENTS SENT A
NOTE SAYING THAT JAMES COMEY,
THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
AND ALL OF HIS LEADERSHIP AIDES
WERE FIRED UP TO GET GOING ON
THE ALPHA BANK ALLEGATION.
WHAT WAS STRIKING ABOUT THAT IS
THAT THE RESEARCHERS THAT PUT
THIS TOGETHER SAID THAT THEY
WERE AFRAID THEY WOULD BE
MOCKED.
THEY ACTUALLY SAID WHAT IF THESE
PEOPLE ARE SMART ENOUGH TO SEE
THROUGH THIS?
HOW ARE WE GOING TO ANSWER THAT.
AND THE RESPONSE WAS WE JUST
NEED A NARRATIVE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE CLINTON PEOPLE WERE RIGHT.
BECAUSE WHEN IT WENT OVER TO THE
FBI, APPARENTLY, ACCORDING TO
THIS AGENT, JAMES COMEY AND THE
REST OF THE FBI WERE CHOMPING AT
THE BIT.
>> Bret: AS WAS THE MEDIA IN
LARGE PART.
LET ME READ THIS FROM ANDY
McCARTHY.
FBI LEADERSHIP DURING RUSSIA
THAT GATE MAKES DURHAM'S TRIAL
SUSSMANN TRIAL TRICKY.
HE SAID HE WASN'T REPRESENTING A
CLIENT WHEN IN FACT HE WAS
REPRESENTING THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN NO.
DOUBT HE SAID IT CASE CLOSED.
DOWN ON EARTH IT'S NEVER THAT
SIMPLE.
THE CRIME
♪ MAKING A FALSE STATEMENT.
IT'S MAKING A FALSE STATEMENT TO
THE FBI.
PROBLEM FOR DURHAM HOW DOES HE
PROVE THAT SUSSMANN'S FALSE
STATEMENT MATTERED WHEN THE
AGENTS WERE ALSO BEING MISLEAD
BY THEIR OWN BOSSES?
GOOD POINT?
>> I ALMOST ALWAYS AGREE WITH
ANDY.
I DISAGREE ON THIS ONE POINT.
THAT IS IT'S TRUE THAT THE
AGENTS WERE TOLD THAT THIS CAME
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT DID.
IT WAS REFERRED THROUGH BAKER.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE REASON
SUSSMANN WENT TO HIM.
BUT BAKER SAID I WOULD HAVE
HANDLED THIS DIFFERENTLY IF I
KNEW IT WAS FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
THE PROBLEM FOR DURHAM IS THE
JURY AND THE JUDGE.
I MEAN, HE IS FACE GUILTYING A
JURY THAT HAS THREE CLINTON
DONORS, AN AOC DONOR, AND A
WOMAN WHOSE DAUGHTER IS ON THE
SAME SPORTS TEAM WITH SUSSMANN'S
DAUGHTER.
I MEAN, WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
RANDOMLY SELECTING PEOPLE OUT OF
THE DNC HEADQUARTERS, YOU COULD
NOT COME UP WITH A WORSE JURY.
>> Bret: WELCOME TO WASHINGTON,